un
homme de la guitarra Americana starring emilio estefan our ability to have a new civilian force
in our society our medina de
la da da da da da da da da la da
da da da da da da da da ba da
da da da la voiture Anna Muhammadan Harvey do I wanna be you who also
yeah
human latina Aminata Papa Pato parte de la de Mouton an 11-2 Simon Yelena
Zhukova community an otaku mean FC marquise de boeuf a la commune has a Java bamboo
marriage' and Kathy Almanza
what
type of water that it s gonna be evil of Han na ma Akane
Deva
yeah unilatina amount of wahoo loophole and Sadie de Guzman our medical wealthy like all the
new become woman very suitable for 30 festivals and Harvey
we
begin the name of Allah all praise and glory be to Allah Lord of the Worlds
we thank him and who seek his health and his garments and his pleasure in his
forgiveness and we
asked him how to protect us from the evil whispers within us and the evil consequences
of our misdeeds from
the number of guides no one can lead astray and remember about leaves or guidance none
can guide that person and testify that no one is worthy of our worship but Allah
alone
finally partners the true supreme king the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu idea Anika said it was in truth his prophet and servant and His
Messenger well
people of Eman happens up low of a block remain conscious and obedient to Allah in
the matter he deserves and do not die except in a state of complete and total
surrender to Allah a state of Islam
to
begin one
of the many many many
many merits
of Islam
is
that it
ensures dignity
for human being in their behavior
it
helps a person become king
calm and collected dignified and composed regardless of what experience circumstances may provoke them or push
to manipulate them
if
a person is trying to observe Islam correctly they
will find it easier than others
to
not have
high blood pressure and the
totally disgruntled totally angered because the men who either ruined their basket won't leave with their
friends as I
heard one elderly man I estimate using a 65 or 70 years old never forget that
he was running up the court from the Thunder began this was the one day him
and his guys get together and so he looked up at the sky that had to
be madness was not a Muslim and he said
we had a deal
angrily
shouting out all of us a panic attack
you
would not be that person that
a good
friend of mine who used to work in the Apple store says about that when the
iPhone six came out we
had her phone the girl that we could online for two three hours what
she had insisted that
it be the pink one and we weren't going to have that for two three more
days she
turned a blaze she went on fire she had a temperature as if she was a
child she went from anger to tears to crying and she leaves the store this time
dignifies a person above such behavior it
dignifies a person above the behavior of a person who said to me I don't care
I
will
refuse
when they ever do that to go to paradise if my wife is inside I don't
care of this problem sends me to the fire my enemy that causes
a person to move not just from adulthood to
childhood but from sanity to insanity from
belief to disbelief under controllable anger our
team came to help a person
beyond that weakness becoming a victim of their own anger
so
in Bukhari and Muslim so
they met it wasn't the amount a guy who says his temper are too lenient than
a piece of above ridiculous and lemon whenever you return to you soon
well
I have new home and a soup would alpha was dead the hullabaloo la habra let's
go two men got into a fight an argument in front of the profits of the
Maserati of Silla while we were there and one of them kept just cursing offending the
other and
he
was in a fit of rage to
the point that he became so angry his face became red we could all see this
man was losing it he
lost his leaders basic for
fallen the Divas of Olive on ETO settling in Nina Arabic any medicine no Ghana had
ever have our humanity the prophets often have said I know a statement that
if he were to say it all that he finds inside of himself that fury inside
of himself would just vanish with disappear are
we will be landing in a shape on the Ragini's Anessa stated you accessing i seek
refuge protection with allah from shaytan the accursed
Ksenia
babu
so I haven't even MRI image ever of the eleven you can Amman the beasts of
Allah already who said then have an eighty five are who be been one of us
I haven't heard message some of love I didn't say this
something was more eyes on the heart so he went to the man who informed him
the messengers of Allah audience and that said this and
then
they said to him to I would be done in this shape on seek refuge with
Allah from Shaitan so
how that other budget and so the man retorts it back to him he snapped back
at him at Taranaki betsa image noon even
hell you
think there's something wrong something's wrong with me am I
am I crazy Shaitaan has possessed me meaning you think I am possessed by a demon
get
out of here get away from leave
and
this
hadith of course is filled with lessons and guiding principle some of them being obviously that
a person must be very careful about their timing when they give advice in general and
also
of the lessons of this hadith is how to deal with angry people in particular
but
what I want to start with in talking about anger management controlling our anger all of
us and how Islam enabled us to do that and showed us the roadmap out of
this dark this dark sphere of anger that consumes so many people
that
the prophets of Allah are either sending them alluded to the fact that anger is from
Shaitaan you
have to seek refuge with Shaitaan when you're angry that means they are the factor at
play it is all
anger from Shaitaan no
only
when its alady huh only when it's unjustified but
the issue is usually most of the time most of us most
of our anger is for personal reasons and if
it's you're taking sides for a personal reason you're already gonna be biased and so
it's not going to be for Allah Norah's it's really going to be about fairness and
justice because you cannot be just when we were one of the two disputants and so
almost all of anger because of that equation this front goes back to being from straight
line
you
feel you assume someone violates your rights
someone
has
shortchanged you in your reputation so you react with anger how
much your active angular depends on who you are and what happened but
not all anglers from Shaitaan we do need to establish standards and
there in and of itself is natural it's
completely natural completely human
of us even though I was not a modern concept that just anchors okay with management
of anger that's not just a modern thing that we talk about nowadays in therapy this
is has always been something understood by the wise among humanity even
though out of they used to say man is still labor when I'm the other love
for who are you know like
whomever is provoked to anger and doesn't become angry their donkey like what do you mean
you slapped across the face in your final minute that
means you're not alive you're not human you have no self-respect you
have you're totally indifferent about even that are you alive what manager can be making it's
in even with the poet says injuries are only not felled by dead people so
long as they're alive the injury is gonna hurt an injury is going to provoke a
reaction from you so
the issue of anger being there is not the problem at all a person
is allowed to become angry and a
lot of place anger inside of us when he created us meaning the propensity to anger
he made us prone to anger to test us right how are you gonna react are
you going to contain that natural anger and then
how will you employ that anger because there are two things here there's natural anger you
need to control that between the balance of a volatile environment and there is righteous anger
we're not just you're allowed to have it you should have it angered
for Allah but that also of course must be regulated by the boundaries of Allah as
elegant as for not becoming angry whatsoever this is completely alien to human nature and to
Islam even in the Koran Allah Celgene says about people that he praises that have earned
his pleasure he says well even loudly boo-boo you have firoun people
that when they become angry they
forgive so
he's not praising them for not becoming angry he's
praising them for forgiving despite being angry
so
the problem with anger is watch them in it
and some of it is even righteous anger the
problem is when it comes from Shaitaan as we said earlier usually it's from shaking
when
Shay bond gets anger
to control you instead
of you controlling it that's
one of the whole dilemma happens when
anger controls you and consumes you and blocks your ability to be sensible to think with
your mind right
not with your emotions what
should I be doing here what's right and what's wrong here what's very unfair what's pleasing
to Allah was that to block your sensibility that's the problem when it blocks your ability
to be patient
your
forbearance to
block your ability to delivery to measure things for the long term to think things through
as they say those
are the problem because these are things that love demands from you so if anger can
hijack these things Shay finally puts you in a very distant dangerous place because
these are not police on my you
know in both ID and Muslim the
prophets of Allah are they who send and receive the delegation and
the leader
of that delegation was a man by the name of Allah change if not the place
and
the
entire delegation rushes to meet the Prophet SAW sullen and their leader who's supposed to go
first that represents their chief they left him behind the luggage and the animals they
all rushed in for that protocol because the Prophet SAW said Allah obviously would make you
forget protocol and so
their eagerness to meet there are still a lot of caused them to forget their respect
that they lived by the honor of their chief their
chief did not though he
tied up the animals and he took off his clothes and put on nicer clothing even
better protocol to
go see the prophets of Allah audience send them in clean attire not patate tyre you've
been traveling with all this time and so
the Messenger of Allah saw Allah hasn't noticed is from him and he said to him
in Navi Cohoes Latini yuhibbu whom Allah who and hidden one attempt he
said in you are two qualities that our love loves him
or variants for you to put up with things that make you angry for variants these
people disrespected you they did something that you would naturally anger you but
you have hidden you shove him and and
that is the liberation when you sit and think things through what's the best way to
behave here and you're not gonna think things through through angry so Haven has to come
before an app for parents so that you can deliberate
so
he thought it through it's better for me to wear my best clothing to wash up
perhaps and then most see the profit some of our body who sent them so the
man was happy and he said the auto salon pas at
Tejada left Oh behemoth and Javon
and endeavour on a Hema yeah also what these two qualities are talking about did
I practice these but did I adopt these consciously or did Allah our surgeon create me
this way he made me more prone to deliberation more prompt forbearance and
so
the prophets of Allah audio setup said to him Benjamin are innate you might know of
what created you this way some people are more prone saying they're some people don't have
that challenge they will have other challenges certain you don't think you've got the short end
of the stick we
will all be tested somewhere in your testing with the short fuse some have a lust
for the opposite genitive some cannot resist wealth and that is their jihad that is their
challenge so he's telling him now this one Allah gives you a freebie on that one
among
created you this way with these qualities that he loves forbearance and deliberation and so he
said and happened to be that met each other landed on a full detainee you hit
aluminum block water so he said come to be better Allah gave me two qualities that
human is less that ian is messenger love and so
when anger sensors these for
merit deliberation senses and civility into life this is when it's from Shaitaan and this is
what happens more often than not especially in today's world that's why this hope was so
important right in today's world that so fast peace there's so much commotion there's so much
interference right there's so
much lack of privacy and there's so much lack of worship also making our lives god
centric centered people
will automatically become more
angry we have more angry people now this is known and expected because of our lifestyle
less worship more fast-paced less deliberation less forbearance less the ability to frustrate to tolerate frustrations
all of that it
will uproot the tree of your faith and
plant
among other things plant the tree called anger it
gets wedged in your life and we just become angry people that's
why I see panel of the wisdom of us have understanding this when they read in
the Quran when a kinkou new rock band ye
do not be people that just have the book you just rush past the verses like
Venice ye do
not be like the nice lady who just rushes past the verses and not takes care
of them not
invites
them in their life adopts them in their life but be people of God or better
he needs people of God truly attached to God I believe of the Obama he said
about this and what does it mean to people of God he said two words all
that food I'm mad in the banana people
that have forbearance and
people
that have knowledge meaning
you
are contained because of your relationship with God right your tree of faith is in there
and so you are contained and you know what Allah wants almost
like we're married to deliberation again to know what you're supposed to be doing regardless of
the outside circumstances the
opposite when you don't have a god centric life and you have a fast-paced world it
will put the tree in danger when the tree of anger is planted in your life
you
can imagine what happens when you're quick to anger this anyone divorced his wife except when
he's angry that's
like a common jump between all of the machete that every time someone says my husband
divorced me because I divorced my wife we
tell them what happened he says but but but I was angry we
tell them what has anyone ever divorced their wife over a cup of tea like obviously
you are angry why else did you divorce
has
anyone ever divorced sent their angry do people insult except that they're angry do people offend
one another slander you're angry at someone who just start thinking it maybe this and maybe
that's all from Trayvon right do
people leave Islam they curse at times the Dean and the home and the claim with
his being and the one who sent down the Quran because they're angry do
people kill except because they're angry do people lie and cheat except to have leverage in
the conversation because they're angry all
of those sins of the tongue I just mentioned these are just sour fruits that grow
on the tree of anger when the tree of anger gets planted in your apartment all
of it comes from the same place and that's why our prophets of Allah Quran is
no syndrome called
our attention to this they catch it he says to us no hatred in our best
merits by the flood and undergo fraud in that humbly Hadouken finesse scoot when
one of you is angry
keep
silent because once anger gets settled it just that's when all those sandwich roots come out
you starts using your tongue in all these ways that are so destructive so dangerous so
on you're angry be silent he said and by
the way of course if you're obligated in Islam to be silent when you're angry so
that's an escalated you're definitely not allowed to eat someone not keeping their children on your
enemy because if you hit because you're angry
you
will not stop hating until you feel a finished or until
you've done something so damaging that it brings you back to your senses around Laguna and
so heating is not allowed to quencher your age in Islam heating
is allowed as a last resort in moderation to discipline not to avenge yourself and if
you cannot control what you're going to say in words are so like and the tongue
is so easy to move that
boneless muscle as they say you can't use it when you're angry then you definitely cannot
use your hands and
so
this is why he is also said I'm tied between the the
tongue and the anger itself because once that tree is planted elderly sour poisonous fruits continue
being spewed out as a result the whole of only other
anyway
having
that work the Seleucid of armament anivia dr.
to the law
that would actually connect West London permanent and arbiter who one of the usual arson and
of course once these words when my angers off contained in these words complying out or
may Allah forbid physical ramifications the
Stations of the anger take place so
many times the damage as people know is
either
irreversible cannot be repaired or so hard to prepare to repair
you
know I remember reading that an intelligence father once noticed very early on that his kid
has anger problems and
so
what he did with him to defuse the situation whenever his kid would lose his
temper he
would have him walk out to the end of their property and and nail a homemade
email into the fence to make sure he went to the end every
time he would lose his temper he would send him on the same task then what
was the punishment he
says on the first day my son took 38 nails in the fence
he
said and gradually the amount of nails he would put in each day was less and
less and less until
he finally got to a day when
he didn't put any nails in the fence and so
I would tell him for every day you
don't lose your temper you can go remove one nail from the fence
he
says without by the time the day came that he actually removed everything from the fence
I took him over to the end of our property to
the property line and I
said to him what do you see you can imagine fence filled with holes he
said you undid all of your temper tantrums you earning it that
but
were you able to repair the holes in the fence sometimes your anger will cause you
to do damage that you cannot prepare and this is especially true with people and possibly
true from us a pattern all the time
sometimes we just blurt things out to say things you do things and the damage no
matter how hard you try people are not gonna love they will not just forgive you
the moment you back to them and
so
the damage leads for a very long time I have cases of children that are traumatized
from the religion of their parents from Islam because of the way they saw their parents
their father treated their mother right
the
domestic violence the battery that happens when Islam itself and then think of the damage that
happened with so many relationships outside of marriage insight all different kinds
so
when the man came to the prophet sallallaahu he will send them and he said to
him out singing this is lame honey give me in at once all of that some
books it don't become angry but
Quran have my Agha father that's up top he kept repeating the question like give me
more advice give me more advice he
told about becoming don't
becoming do not become angry in
the narration of this hadith visit there's an extra word in a commentary narrated by a
talking on love this man says it took me advice he
says
Calvin hey Ana Paula and Andy you sallallahu alayhi wa sallam upon
the
heath album
yes Mary shout McCune level he said when I when he finally refused to give me
any more advice I start to think about it why is he telling me only this
and I
realize that this
qualities learning me from cautioning me against contains all the evil inside of it
why
do you think the Prophet SAW Stalin did give him anymore twice there are so many
other a hadith when he tells people that ask him al cine advice he gives and
different prices he
wanted this person and us as well to know that getting passed don't become angry it's
not easy it's a mission right
you're
not going to go do it overnight and likewise I say now don't think our problem
with anger in general in our generation in our impulsive or compulsive generation is going to
be done with comfortable and
I plan and charm up to give you two more fulness one of them is inspiration
on how there are the Muslims Delta's anger because we kind of identified other it's natural
it's an inspiration it's extremely useful and the third of them how to deal with angry
people but
I wanted this whole book to begin on how to deal with angry me my
anger itself how
to get past that how
to conquer our own anger the good news is that how to delete that countering your
anger is certainly possible because the problems are said have shown us ways to do it
but it's going to require training not a football as he
said is not wassalam in a manner in mauritania when a man hits a handle when
he never saw you lose the support that
you learning knowledge is to learn okay so I'm sorry I'm just not a smart person
no
that's easy when I could carve a lot a lot let that go you have to
try to learn
whenever you move it's a highly loom and developing forbearance the ability to restrain anger that's
through practicing forbearance trying one time and trying again and slipping and resting up and apologizing
and coming back around well you never saw with the support and patience is still training
yourself conditioning yourself foundations and of
the tips that he gave us and with that I'll close the whole bottom of the
tips
he gave us on a sloth was set up to get past to help us in
this course in this training course to get past our anger and all the damage it
causes for our dunya and our team number one is the ayah that we said to
seek refuge with Allah from Shaytan emerging from the cursor shape on this is the first
of them the second of them we say is do not speak when you're angry when
you become angry walk
out shudders be
silent
because
one word will lead to a response which will step up your anger another level it
will escalate it so to be silent
number
three is for
you if you're standing to sit down this Italian sauce a la valle de la luna
yakame
phantom
orange moon other way enact vania budget when one of you is
then angry and standing let them sit down change positions right
deescalate the situation and
this
will do a wing with your energy said and if it doesn't lay down one
time they saw a blue member of the 11-hundred was known to have intense emotions in
the middle of a conversation just laid down some there should be sax and Lenny late
then can imagine talking to someone hold
the sudden they're just they
sit down and they'll 8000 what are you doing he said I heard the public saw
some say this this is a man who cared what is hereafter and cared about his
relationships that will extend into the Hereafter this is the person who took this mission seriously
not to say hey listen you know I'm an angry person deal with it that
doesn't work the
believer that is observant of am on the last day does not
sign
themselves off of the mission like that so we said it's the eye and he says
be silent we said if you're standing sit or lay down also
read about the virtues of restraining your anger and they are so many in the Quran
of this women our promise also them said the strong person is actually the first that
restrains their anger you're not out wrestles others he said in another hadith sorry
let's
talk about what a continued do
not be angry don't get angry at for us perilous
for
a person that wants to get in states a lot in
his life that means something you know if you were angry in about to do something
and someone stuck a gun to your head you'd back off you'd count that something okay
okay alright gonna rescue me don't shoot me don't this right the
believers should have you offer agenda to be one of those light bulbs serving okay definitely
worth it fine I'll take the hit I'll swallow that's our bill I'll do it so
to realize the virtues of
restraining your anger and also the flipside of that the dangers of leaving your anger uncontrolled
the
last one
that I mentioned for this will spot for this whole bunch on mama and then
some and just people have observed an experience when you find yourself angry go
look at yourself in the mirror you
want to recognize yourself you'll
feel like this is not to me like it's shaped by the air or like who
is this guy who is this person help yourself psych yourself out if you're angry
as
with
the other things like the Senate are righteous friend how they dealt with anger that's inexcusable
in sha allah and of course the rod goes all across the board beginning during and
after
the mission as our Prophet SAW said I used to say was Anakin
he's in the West End of got cost less alcohol
that have to feel a little bubble and I ask you a true statement to be
contained in my words whether I'm pleased or whether I'm angry and we ask some are
subject to help us with this guy these guiding principles of Islam help us improve our
relationships first with him and with his creation of aam aadmi may Allah make us of
those thats a statement of truth and judge Harry whether we are pleased with whether we
are angry we all must Okinawa trying to bring our hearts together and bring our behavior
aligned with the guidance of his prophets allah la ilaha illa allah wa nahnu homina homina
homina
the
new banner a monofin anikanova Nawaz la da de da da da da da Vanina Wadena
Saguna Sarah Tina
Subaru Sarah Magina Mary Lou Marzian o
bones of Islam are famously mean why didn't achieve khaliqeen of mama in America that had
a MMA but often a Donatella Finocchiaro Elena masala wasallam of our economy gentlemen were the
heroes of abusive